hey what's up you guys time for the
movie retrospective
doing some british horror today yeah and
some folk horror kind of a lesser known
folk horror movie i feel like yeah
but uh yeah so this came out what i said
it's just a 70s british flick
kind of like a damn
i don't know
like a witchcraft movie it's exactly
what it is yeah definitely um and this
is kind of like this was actually
because you know if you know anything
about british horror you know your big
behemoths of like the 60s and 70s was
hammer studios who kind of did sort of
victorian era stuff more classical
gothic stuff and then you had amicus
that usually did uh anthology movies or
portmanteau movies uh in the british
parlance yeah but there was also a much
smaller kind of scrappy sort of
production company called taigon yeah
that's the first i don't even know that
tygon exists yeah i was watching this
and i thought
yeah i'm a i'm a big fan of hammer
because hammer's broke boobalicious yeah
it is it is they're definitely selling
sex on that one but in a good way and
then uh amicus is a little dryer i
always thought it was kind of dry this
movie's trying to give you like the best
of both worlds if you ask me they're
trying to give you kind of the realism
and they're also trying to throw some
boobs in there
yeah there's boobs in here and yeah
there's a bunch of sex and stuff
but yeah it's mostly innuendo you do see
some nudity it's not as gratuitous not
as sexy and high-end as hammer hammers
had a lot of style to it too you know
real good-looking european actresses and
cool uh you know cool actors and [ __ ]
and really good sets and this is
this is more about realism less style
more realism and i guess you could say
in a way and it's a monster movie
witches and [ __ ]
yeah it's like a witchcraft movie like i
said it's folk horror usually when you
talk about british folk horror
specifically uh most people talk about
witchfinder general which came out in
1968 with vincent price which was also
done by tygon
yeah this one felt a lot like that movie
and then yeah it was the same production
company and um and also obviously the
wicker man which actually came out a
couple years after this okay now you see
it now i didn't know that that was the
same company that did wicker man yep
well no it's not the same company
wickerman it's the same company that did
witch finder general okay did this movie
i thought you said it was no i just said
the wicker man came out a couple years
after this as another one that's like a
british horror like folk yeah it has
that focal horror angle you'll see it it
this one to go right along in with some
of the more recent folk horror movies
you know mid-summer and stuff it's like
that yeah there's been kind of a
folklore revival uh lately and honestly
if you guys if you have shutter
they just added a whole bunch of folk
horror movies including this one um
which i think they had this one before
but they added a whole bunch of other
ones i think this is also on 2b actually
um but there's this really awesome
documentary that shutter just added and
it's called um what's it called
darklings what [ __ ] no it's called
what's i have it written down somewhere
where the hell is it it's called
woodlands dark and days bewitched uh and
it's a history of folk horror and it's
over three hours long and it is
fascinating it's not just british folk
or it's folk or everywhere it's american
folk horror which included kind of like
old zombie you know haitian voodoo type
films uh and it's like folk horror from
around the world and you know the recent
folklore revival was stuff like you know
the witch and hagazusa and stuff like
that and it's like it's really really
interesting and there was like a whole
[ __ ] ton of movies in there that i had
actually never heard of so
you know it's really expanded my movie
list but yeah so
in case we didn't mention it this is
called the blood on satan's claw that's
actually what it was released as in the
u.s i think originally i think it's
generally regarded by that name now but
i think when it originally came about
came out in the uk i think it was called
satan's skin i've also seen it under the
title uh the devil's touch
um those actually are better i think
they're yeah they do make more sense
because honestly now satan's skin is
closer to yeah what actually happens in
the movie although i will note
that
the thing that happens like the i guess
it's like a demon that gets brought up
in the it's not technically satan
it's behemoth yeah uh they actually say
who it is they eventually show it
it does look kind of corny but it's an
old movie okay
and this the budget on this was very low
i think 82 000 pounds yeah uh was how
much this grew up on old tom baker
doctor who you'll recognize it's that
level of uh costume work but it's good
though i like it i grew up watching that
kind of [ __ ] you know but you see the
thing you're like oh okay so that's the
demon it is it took me a while to um
understand exactly what was going on
jenny kind of has the advantage over me
because she knows a lot about witchcraft
and witchcraft books and witchcraft
stories and all the tropes so and she
had seen the movie before so she knew
what was coming it i was kind of not
really understanding what was happening
in the movie for a bit but then once
once i realized what it was they were
trying to reassemble this demon
it it it made a lot more sense um
it's weird you know they did
witchcraft stories do weird [ __ ] each
follower is growing a part of the damn
demon and they're gonna cut that off and
assemble the demon that way which that's
wild man that's a wild idea i wish
they'd had more money to show that in a
different in a better way it grossed you
out
like they would do from like heredity or
something that that idea had been really
good
i don't think i've ever seen that done
in another movie i mean i'm sure there
might have been but that was like that's
like a really good idea yeah they're
sacrificing body parts to assemble this
thing and it's gonna be alive and it's
gonna fight and [ __ ]
and it's all these and and it was weird
is that
satanism there's like an outbreak of
satan worshipers
in the way that it's kind of like
vampires they don't really explain how
it spreads from one to the other it's
just next thing you know all these damn
teenagers are worshiping satan back in
the 1500s
it's not it no it's the 18 no it's the
1700s okay i think it's 18th century
they were wearing those pilgrim looking
outfits i thought it was 1500s but it
doesn't matter it's fairly it's
more recent okay
that must have been their religion it
was making them wear that
because they were priests a lot of them
remember the round collars and
everything
yeah brown white collars it was just it
was a real rural it was a rural
uh village kind of you know
in england yeah it's um like i said i
don't uh i kind of feel like it's out of
the what they call the unholy trinity of
british folk horror which like i said
witch finder general this movie wicker
man i kind of feel like this is the
least
remembered or the least seen
um which is kind of a shame because i i
actually really like this one good movie
now interestingly um it does come across
and i guess i didn't realize this the
first time because i've this is the
second or third time that i watched it
when we watched it for this review
um and i didn't know this going in but
the movie originally conceptually
started out as and it's interesting
because almost kind of like you said
it's halfway between hammer and amicus
this the concept of this movie actually
started out being
an anthology it was actually going to be
three sort of interlocking stories one
of which was about a young girl who gets
trapped in her or who gets locked in her
attic by her aunt
one of which was about a guy who
cuts his own demonically possessed hand
off
and one in which a bunch of kids in a
village find like a weird corpse like a
weird body
so if you've seen the movie you know
that all of those elements come into
play and
when they decided to make this into one
narrative um actually i think originally
the idea was it was going to be set in
the victorian era
but when they were talking about they're
like well there's been so many horror
movies set in the victorian era maybe
everybody's kind of sick of it so they
decided to move it to like 18th century
rural england and uh you know we're
going to have it in this kind of
backwoods farming community and we're
gonna put all of the stories together
into one narrative
um and to a large extent it works but
knowing that it started out as an
anthology i think that will become a lot
clearer because the pace of the movie is
a little bit episodic i will say that so
if you're not really like following
along with what's going on you're like
wait who are these people now or what
was how what happened with that guy or
whatever it's it so i think they did a
good job like integrating all the
stories into one thing but
there are parts that because like
for example like at the very beginning
of the movie um the first thing that
happens is there's this farmer that
lives in this village and his name's
ralph gower and he's tilling the field
and he finds this weird ass looking
skeleton essentially except it still has
like an eyeball and it has like looks
like it has weird fur on it's all like
[ __ ] up looking
and he's like flipping out so he goes
and tells the judge he's played by uh
patrick wymark this was his last movie
by the way he actually died before it
came out he died quite young he was only
50.
and um so he goes and tells the judge
the judge even though he's kind of like
i guess he's more of like a city guy so
he's just kind of like oh you backwards
country people and you're silly
superstitions this is a bunch of
[ __ ] yeah he's like witches that's
not a thing anymore what the [ __ ] and
then when he goes back and the guy's
like no for sure for real like come and
see this weird body and so he goes and
of course it's gone then
now after that though there goes into
this little thing where there's another
dude in the village this really really
tall skinny dude with like really long
hair and he brings home his betrothed
whose name is uh rosalind
and he's like staying with his aunt
who's a stone cold [ __ ] by the way this
like old battle axe yeah she thinks
she's pregnant and everything
well yeah yeah the old lady doesn't
think she's breaking she thinks the
other girl is breaking her hair because
you knocked her up and now but now she
now you have to marry her because i was
gonna be up in the damn attic yeah so
it's obviously that's like well she's
not even supposed to be staying in the
house because that's so improper but
it's like we'll make her stay up in like
the stinky attic where nobody nobody
lives nobody's been up there for like a
really long time meet you up there yeah
he's like after everybody
okay we'll get on this yeah and so then
like but she's up there and then like
some creepy [ __ ] happens like the floor
starts creaking and then she starts
screaming her head off and
instead of you know everybody else in
the house being like oh my gosh i wonder
what's the matter with her uh the aunt
and the judge who's also kind of staying
there they're just like yeah let's just
lock her in there and then we'll call
like the
we'll call the people from the mental
asylum and come take her away because
clearly she's got some problems
so that so that happens and then so the
next morning they come and take her away
like to the asylum and she's just kind
of like coming out of there like that's
right [ __ ] and then like she has
a hand like that and she has claws now
you don't see that woman again and that
woman is not like brought up again so
like i said that things like that you
can see like where this movie started
out
anthology
yeah like she presumably goes off to the
you know the to the asylum no she went
to a mental assignment but they had the
hand though
well no because i think that the hand
was either from her or it was from part
of the body that they found so she was
drawing that claw for nothing
i guess or yeah maybe they took it from
her but see that's against another thing
they didn't really make that super clear
like where because it looked like at the
beginning of the movie where the farmer
like finds the
remains
of the demon you're meant to assume
that's going to be resurrected
um
you it almost just looks like a head but
it could be like maybe the claw was in
there with it or maybe yeah so she was
growing a claw yeah the head had eyes in
it too it had one eye and then it had
like like worms and [ __ ] coming out of
the side it might have been reassembling
or something it's weird because they
start being afflicted by satanism and it
starts off as a patch of skin that's why
they called it this devil's skin and
satan's skin and it starts growing and
it takes over a whole body part and then
later on in the movie they're having
this big ritual in their chop they gotta
chop off that body part and they're
gonna assemble this damn demon and that
this big ritual they're having orgies
and [ __ ] it's pretty cool
yeah it's a yeah so it's just kind of
like and so the guy who's uh fiance gets
taken off to the asylum
you're led to assume that she was i
guess the first victim of this demon
that came out of the earth yeah somehow
that hand showed back up right like one
thing that's really interesting that uh
that the director whose piers haggard by
the way in case i didn't who he also did
a couple he did uh the crater mass
conclusion he'd finish plotted dr
fumanchi like the ones yeah he did that
one um so
he really wanted um and this is a very
folk horror-y type of trope he's like a
lot of the shots in the movie are low
angle he's like because i wanted to give
the impression
that whatever this evil was it was like
seeping out of the ground yeah
it's good camera work in it yeah which
like i said that's kind of like a very
folk horror like the horror comes from
the land like a lot of it's rural
particularly british folk horror not you
know not around the world
but yeah so
uh so after that happens it's just kind
of like
it the same guy who's uh whose
fiance was taken off to the asylum
he goes and sleeps up in the attic room
later
and thinks that he sees presumably the
demon and he tries to cut its hand off
but then he finds out that he has
actually cut his own hand off uh you
know in his confusion or in delusion
whatever like the demon is showing him
yeah it's using witchcraft aren't you
yeah it's using witchcraft on you
essentially but the thing about it
though is that
you know some most of the kids
immediately get on board with this satan
worshiping thing yeah not really
explained again not explaining it's like
an outbreak of vampirism because they
they lose their identities they're just
they just like satan and they're turning
on people and committing murders i just
like satan i don't know it doesn't
really explain how it happens just it's
just an outbreak of it kind of like
they've been bitten by something
they get possessed i guess that'd be a
good one they get possessed yeah it's
just kind of like and they don't really
explain either why uh angel blake who is
kind of like the town hottie played by
linda hayden by the way who was also in
taste the blood of dracula a lot of
hotties in the movie there are a lot of
uh and actually the girl that plays
kathy uh in this was one of the early
companions on doctor who yeah which i
think she was on doctor who like right
around the same time that this movie
came out yeah okay i didn't recognize
her yeah she played yeah so um yeah so
she probably wasn't playing sarah was
she sarah jane smith
no i think her no she was uh i think her
name was zoe she was zoe zoey okay yeah
sounds familiar but i think so that
would have been like early 70s yeah i
don't quite remember that sidekick
yeah but yeah she was on there i think
around the time that this movie came out
yeah i got man i want to get some of
those old doctor who's in tom baker yeah
those were good but yeah so angel blake
who like i said she's kind of like the
the town hottie and
she for whatever reason um after this
you know other woman rosalind gets taken
away
angel blake becomes kind of like the the
focus of the possession and because
she's so popular in the village you're
led to assume uh she's able to get most
of the other kids and we say kids but
it's mostly like teenagers to be honest
with you they're pretending to be
teenagers i think they're a lot older
than they're supposed to be well yeah
there's nude scenes and [ __ ] although uh
i will say that that actress linda
hayden yeah uh who was naked in this
yeah she's 17. okay that was legal
though yeah i mean you know some
nowadays nowadays kind of questionable
uh you wouldn't be able to get away with
that nowadays but uh yeah in 1971 you
probably yeah you couldn't say anymore
but uh yeah so she does get naked in
this but yeah i think i'm pretty i'm
pretty sure she was only seven as long
as it wasn't considered to be porn they
could they could yeah she was just
standing there right i mean really she
wasn't uh doing anything that no sexual
yeah i mean it was she was being
seductive but she wasn't it was
simulated right it wasn't a real thing
so it's just kind of like so she for
whatever reason becomes sort of like the
the ring leader i guess yeah and so she
gets all of the other kids in the
village to go along with it and they all
pretty much they start going out in the
woods and playing and singing and [ __ ]
like that and also
they start targeting other kids in the
village who
either i it's it's weird because the two
that they uh that they target at first
who's mark and his sister kathy
they're not so much it's not so much
that they're like oh we don't want to do
the whole satan thing thank you and
they're like okay we have to kill you
now it's almost just like well they
didn't get on board quick enough so
they're just gonna kill him but then the
thing about it though too is that
all of the kids have
uh patches of hair on them
and it's not just kids because some of
the people in the satan cult are like
old people and stuff like that too
because they do show it later on so it
seems like even if you don't accept the
whole demonic thing
then the hair's still gonna grow on you
and i guess at that point if you're not
willing to go along they're gonna take
it by force i guess is what they're
talking about and uh if you fall into
the custody of people who aren't
possessed they'll you'll sit there and
straight up tell them that you that
you're you belong to satan and you just
like you can't control yourself
even if they cut that patch of skin off
you
it doesn't break this i guess spell they
you're still a satanist it's kind of
like and they kind of act they kind of
act the way a vampire
thrall would act
yeah that's a good way of playing with
their like yeah they get like totally
kind of mesmerized like sucked into this
whole cult thing right to a point where
yeah we're just gonna kill yeah so it's
just kind of like so they kill mark
um you know they kind of lure him away
and uh just kill him and like throw him
in the woodshed and then they straight
up like go and tell his mom hey we just
killed your kid and she's like what the
[ __ ] and then she goes and finds the
body and obviously she's really upset
and then they start targeting um the
sister kathy
and this scene probably the most
infamous in the movie and it's pretty uh
shocking for 1971. um
they the whole uh cult of teenagers and
a couple of old people
uh they basically tear her clothes off
and like rape her while everybody's
watching and making like these really
gross
like getting off facial expressions like
they're getting off on it yeah the girls
and it's like they're just like oh yeah
i wouldn't say yeah and it's like it's
really like
the first time i saw this movie i was
like holy [ __ ] yeah
like for 1971 it's pretty uh it doesn't
really show anything no no but i mean
the implication of it and honestly the
most horrifying thing about it i thought
was not only um that that girl's face
like because she's looks like really
terrified as you would be um but then
like they show all the other like kids
in the village like these old people
like kind of like smacking their lips at
it like they just think it's the hottest
thing ever the young girls the young
girls are [ __ ] rubbing one out and
[ __ ] and [ __ ] getting off on it yeah
it was it's pretty uh yeah well satan's
got him it's celestine's got him see
that they're trying to break you out and
it didn't cost anything that's true it
didn't cost anything it was a free
effect
they put that in the movie they knew
what they're doing yeah it's like so i
kind of feel like though because you
could argue i feel like this isn't quite
as i was going to use the word
exploitative but that's not really that
that has a negative connotation and i
don't mean it like that it's a good
movie yeah it's just that um this does
have some kind of shocking uh you know
sexual violence and other kind of
violence in it as well
but it's not it's not actually played
for titillation in the way like a horror
a hammer horror would no no the hammer
would have been real sexy yeah it would
have just been like hi i'm a sexy
vampire look at my boobies you know what
i mean everybody's consensual yeah
whereas this one is more just kind of
like
you know what i mean well it was a lot
like mid-summer like the week yeah it's
happening it's it's which i imagine
mid-summer you know was it was modeled
after full core like this oh yeah
everything's kind of disorienting you're
like what
that's that was that's the idea yeah
this one did definitely have a very
disorienting kind of like unsettling
kind of vibe to it weird weird [ __ ] yeah
it is really weird so it's not like
another thing that's interesting about
it too is that
in a way you kind of have you know how
like in witchfinder general which we
reviewed not too long ago um you know
that was based on a real dude obviously
matthew hopkins who
you know in the context of the movie
they're making him i mean he's the
villain right uh he's going around
killing all these innocent women like
accusing them of witchcraft and he
doesn't give a [ __ ] if they're really
witches or not he just wants the money
right and so he's portrayed as like a
villain
whereas in this movie i kind of feel
like it's more
ambiguous because the character of the
judge which if you're just kind of
looking at this movie in sort of like a
traditional folklore kind of way the tr
the the character the judge would be
seen as somebody kind of like the witch
finder general character you know played
by vincent price in that movie who was a
bad guy but in this one it almost seems
like at the beginning they're kind of
setting him up to be the bad guy in in
the sense that he's like i don't believe
this [ __ ] whatever it's just like he
comes across as real uh kind of like
dismissive and he's you know thinks the
country people are stupid but he thought
the [ __ ] was ridiculous and all this
other kind of stuff but in the end it
almost seems like and then you have like
the wicker man where it almost seemed
like i don't want to know if say the
wicker man like made the pagans like the
good guys but it was almost kind of like
neither one of them were good yeah they
were both they were both believing in
delusions the wicker man yeah the wicker
people and the christians were both
deluded this one is kind of more like i
don't even know if it would neces was is
necessarily saying that like the
christians or whoever like the
persecuting of the pagans were good guys
but
it like i said it it is a lot more
ambiguous than some of the other ones
were like i said he just became a
believer in the supernatural he saw it
yeah and he was willing to do like he
doesn't torture that girl margaret like
toward the end
um and you do actually feel sympathy for
her even though she is enthralled to
satan and is totally proud of it yeah
i'm satan's kid he did the right thing
though he didn't do anything to her yeah
he didn't really do anything he did like
threaten to but he didn't actually hurt
him at the end when the whole satanic
plot is foiled and the demon is
destroyed it
it implies that the kids that that the
possession ended and they were released
from it yeah
because they look like they went normal
yeah i mean at least ralph who had
started to now he didn't really get in
on the whole thing but he got kind of
sucked into it later and then he grows
all the satan fur like on his leg and so
he was going to cut off his own leg that
was like the last piece of the demon
like at the final kind of thing
so they they so evidently they weren't
really responsible for the crimes that
they were committing
yeah it was the demon taking them over
possessed so yeah destroyed the demon
and it looked like they were all
released although i will say that the
original i believe the original version
of the script um they were actually
going to have a way more bummer ending
where they basically just like killed
everyone in the village like to wipe out
the
the
demonic
just stop it yeah that's what they were
gonna do but then they thought good too
yeah that actually would have been a
good ending too but i kind of like that
they soften i don't usually like when
they soften endings like that but i kind
of feel like like you said it wasn't
really the kid's fault no um you know it
was the demon and the demon was just uh
you know presumably dug by accident by
just somebody that was like plowing the
vehicle because satanism was more like a
plague it came across as kind of like
vampirism being a plague or zombie
outbreak they were like that too they
were kind of like the zombies but they
could talk
they just were committing crimes yeah
and they were trying to assemble this
thing and but they really weren't under
they really didn't have their own will
they were doing it you know the masters
coming that kind of thing you know yeah
and it happened really quickly yeah you
know that's one thing like i said in the
movie the the pacing is very quick so
some things if you're really not paying
attention
one you can tell that you know it was
sort of structured originally as
anthology because you know some
characters like that like the [ __ ]
battle axe aunt at the beginning yeah
she disappears too they just said oh she
disappeared and then they never
mentioned it again
you could tell it's gonna be an
anthology and then he just cobbled it
together in one story yeah but it still
like makes sense and it still has a
three line though but um but yeah i
actually really like this one and i
think it's like really a shame i don't
think it's quite as good as witchbinder
general or wickerman no but um but it's
there but it's different it's kind of
doing something different with it like i
said the whole notion of
constructing the demon's body
out of pieces of you of you like you're
growing this little bit of like kind of
werewolf hair like on your leg or you're
growing some claws or some [ __ ] like
that and then they're gonna take it and
assemble them at the end that's a great
concept even the kids who are possessed
like one guy his whole leg is basically
the devil's leg yeah they hand him a
knife you know on the ceremony
he's getting himself worked up to
[ __ ] cut it off
it was actually from the knee down
wasn't it i think it was the knee down
yeah i mean you couldn't really tell
because he just like pulled it up his
pants like yeah but it's just kind of
like so even though even if even though
you were possessed it wasn't easy to do
they were they were kind of well he
hadn't been uh
so as i said i think and i only just
this only only just occurred to me
really because i'm sitting there going
why did the cult kill someone like mark
and kathy and stuff and then uh not kill
other ones and the other people seemed
willing i guess it was just a sense just
a question of who accepted the demon
and then the other people just didn't
even know about it or didn't accept the
demon but everybody was gonna have the
pieces growing on them yeah and if they
didn't willingly give the demon the
piece of them because they took them
then the cult was just gonna take it
yeah it's probably or they were going to
like hypnotize because like i said the
one character at the beginning
um what the hell was that character's
name the guy that was gonna uh marry
rosalind i can't remember what his name
was but uh the the real tall lanky tall
young guy with the yeah and um he
actually cut off his own hand but he
didn't do it like on purpose like yay
demon he did it because he thought he
was it tricked him he yeah he thought he
was like hurting the demon but he was
actually cutting off his own hand but i
mean what a great idea and honestly i'm
not going to do this yeah that's what i
was just going to say i'm not really
into oh let's remake it but i think this
might be a good one to remake and
especially nowadays like in the last you
know 10 20 years when you've seen this
huge resurgence
in folk horror and people are like
really interested in it and i think this
might be a good one to remake because
it's got a really great concept behind
it
this would go right there with
mid-summer and heredity or hereditary
hereditary yeah yeah that that be right
there well and one's like i think it was
kind of better than a red terry if you
ask me in certain waves
well yeah i don't know i wouldn't say
hereditary was modern okay yeah this
one's not this one's 18th century and i
kind of feel like well this one is more
like you know like the witch from 2016
or
uh you know robert eggers movie or you
know something like that where uh
again it's just it's this kind of going
back to this folk horror kind of thing
and you don't really see a lot of movies
set during this time period like i said
i kind of feel like there's a lot set in
the victorian era there's a lot setting
earlier than this you know what i mean
like with 16th century uh whereas this
one is a little bit later but it's still
kind of like an agrarian
uh you know real rural community that
maybe is still hanging on to their old
ways i thought it was fifteen or sixteen
hundreds no it yeah it's actually uh
it's actually yeah i think it's i think
it's 18th century it's supposed to be so
1700 and uh yeah so
so there's that because i think that um
at one point the judge
says something about uh
is it james iii or something like that i
kind of feel like he says something
about that so
it's interesting too because i don't
know a lot like a huge amount about
british history from this time period
but i think this was kind of a
a time of sort of like religious dissent
and a kind of other so that kind of
gives it a little bit of a different
spin on it and especially like the
character of the judge who
even though he's supposed to be there
with elon he's in this kind of like
rural community but he thinks they're
all backward like he doesn't believe in
witches he doesn't you know he's from
london he's from the city like he just
thinks this is all like silly yeah
that's just from a couple hundred years
ago
right right so i think that kind of put
an interesting spin on it as well yeah
now really the only thing that i can
knock this material this is probably
like budgetary i'm sure
i kind of felt like the the final
confrontation like at the last you know
thing where they were gonna assemble the
demon and he was gonna like manifest
i feel like that was a little truncated
it was a little short um
and like i said i guess i mean they
couldn't really show i like that they
didn't really show the demon all that
much
honestly i kind of wish they'd shown him
a little bit less because when they do
show him like toward the end it looks
like a dude in a costume a little bit
doctor who 1975. it is very much i
probably the same company same guys that
made it it might have been yeah it might
have been which you know you're you'd be
used to it if you're if you grew up
in you know watching british stuff in
the 70s you go oh okay yeah you'd accept
it yeah the way it looked well i mean i
accepted it too i just kind of feel like
i heard an audience be like wait a
minute what yeah it's stylized it's a
stylized costume
that you know is obviously a costume you
don't accept it for it's symbolic for
the damn demon it's not actually you're
not supposed to buy it realism is not
what they were going for when they made
those kind of
costumes for the movies and [ __ ] yeah
i mean the trip yeah the special effects
they have nowadays they could actually
make like a really badass looking demon
that actually looked like real pieces of
fur of like different people like all
patched together that would actually be
pretty cool
it's just a theatrical costume very
style yeah but honestly it's not even
that i kind of feel like
the last part of it is just it's just a
little too short yeah that's all it's
just kind of like you know the the final
thing is taking place and then like the
judge and the other townsfolk are like
just hiding watching it and then they're
like okay now they stand up and then
they stab everybody and then he kills
angel and stuff like that so
i just kind of wish they had like maybe
made that a little bit longer maybe
maybe made it more of like a fight
yeah the thing is is that
70s british stuff of this type
they weren't really into action
choreography it would they they were
more into like shakespearean theater
yeah that's true that's really what what
they were doing so i understand it's
like out of doctor who there's no fight
scenes in doctor who everything is
theatrical like shakespearean yeah [ __ ]
that you but that made for tv and that's
that's what they did
yeah i get that yeah that's what it is
but yeah i'm just saying yeah just don't
expect like some big [ __ ] final
conflict confrontation the strength of
this movie is that they made a very
watchable movie with a bunch of good
ideas to trip you out back in the 70s
with nothing but good actors good
costumes and a good script and in real
locations
that's what you got there was no special
effects to speak of
no flim flam really
it's uh no money
just pure writing and talent and acting
that's it yeah and it's a honestly yeah
it's a it's a fun movie it's it's a it's
a great story it's kind of a different
take like i said on the folklore thing
it has a good look
it has a good spooky look and it's just
like something off the damn
black sabbath one album cover you know
it's like that
witches and [ __ ] yeah witches and [ __ ]
which is the [ __ ] in england out in the
woods in old buildings with [ __ ] 17
year old hotties and old-fashioned
clothes taking their clothes off
preachers and [ __ ] scientists type
dudes and judges and [ __ ] trying to
figure it out
people cutting patches of skin off
throwing witches in the lake
dude eventually shows up with a damn
sword that's got to be eight feet long
with [ __ ] it's got
this side just like one of those swords
that they used to you know kill horses
with
you know with knights that's what kind
of sword that was yeah they used to have
a special kind of sword it was real big
like that it had a big old hilt on
either side
and it was something you used to cut the
legs off of a damn night's horn off of a
nice nice horse you know that's what
that was that's not but he's he attacks
the damn well i know you got a type
charging at you you know on a horse you
do what you can you know it's like the
horse is like man i'm just the dude just
on my back i didn't have anything to do
with this come on
yeah so but but he pulled out that big
sword and killed that demon with it in a
single stroke so not much of a fight
scene but that's not what it was that's
not the british weren't
doing that kind of stunt thing
in movies at that time not yet
yeah i guess not if they did it was
going to be later on or bigger budget
like the one the psychomania remember
the one with the demon there was things
like action scenes in that but they were
dealing with more money
that's true yeah this one was very like
i said tygon was kind of
you know they they their budgets were
not approaching uh you know hammer level
or anything like that these are drama
troops making a movie
yeah
yeah and you know and they work
in that context absolutely so honestly
like if you really like british folk or
like the wicker man and stuff and you
haven't seen this one then definitely
you should see this one like i said it's
a little bit of a different take on it
um it's on shutter at the moment i think
it might also be on to be but i'm not
entirely sure as i said if you do have
shutter though i would really recommend
if you have like three and a half hours
to kill uh go watch that history of folk
horror documentary called woodland stark
and days bewitched it's really really
good and it like i said it's not just
british folklore it's all around the
world and it brought up like so many
different movies that i hadn't heard of
and it's just it's really exhaustive and
it's really really interesting and uh it
talks a little bit about this one talks
a little about the wicker man and stuff
like that but it talks about all
different folk horror from everywhere
and it's like really really good so uh
yeah that'll do it for this movie
retrospective we will see you guys on
the next one
bye
you